[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre recette dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 13 septembre
un caisson de réemploi a pris place à la
déchetterie de Montini le Bretonneux le
principe déposer un objet usagé pour lui
offrir une nouvelle vie s'il n'est pas
réutilisable la dé le prend en charge
sinon trois associations locales
viennent le récupérer une action
bénéfique pour l'environnement le Jamel
Comedy Club le Secours populaire et la
ville de trapppe organise un gala
caritatif pour venir en aide au peuple
marocain suite au tremblement de terre
survenu vendredi dernier pendant 1 he 6
humoristes vont se succéder sur la scène
de laamise dimanche à 15h les
informations dans cette émission besoin
d'un grand bol d'air frais en cette
période de rentrée les Yvelines
regorgent de chemins de randonnées
diverses et varié balade en forêt ou
plutôt promenade champêtre le
département a tout ce qu'il vous faut
pour vous satisfaire nous avons demandé
conseil à l'association Les clésandoau
et enfin en deuxè partie d'émission
l'invité du 78 jusqu'au 17 septembre
c'est le World cleanup day les ville de
Saint-Quentin en yeline propose de
nombreuses opérations de nettoyage en
bas de chez vous on fait le point avec
l'association yvelinoise je respecte la
[Musique]
ville typiquement les objets peut
déposer qu'on peut
trouver du petit mobilier de
l'électroménager des livres de la déco
le principe est simple vous déposez vos
objets usagés et leur offrez une
nouvelle vie à Montini le Bretonneux
dans l'une des SEP déchetteries de
canttin en yeline un caisson de reemploi
peut être utilisé par les habitants le
but de l'initiative ne pas créer de
déchets dans la lignée de ce qu'on
essaie de mettre en place he depuis 2016
que la compétence a été transférée des
communes vers l'agglomération l'objectif
fait toujours d'aller vers moins de
déchets donc ça se traduit par
différentes actions notamment bah la
dernière en date c'est la création de ce
caisson après quelques difficultés au
démarrage le dispositif s'inscrit
aujourd'hui dans le quotidien des
antinois la déchetterie a récolté 200 kg
d'objets au mois d'août contre 50 en
avril jouets DVD meubles et même vélo
les habitants jouent le jeu c'est la
première fois effectivement que je
dépose mes mes objets ici habituellement
je vais chez Maus qui est pas très loin
de la maison ça puisse être recyclé et
et que ça puisse servir à d'autres
personnes géré par trois associations
ressourcez-vous la bicyclette et
emmaustrap la restauration est assurée
dans leurs ateliers si l'objet n'est pas
réutilisable il basculle dans les
filières de traitement traditionnell
c'est vraiment bénéfique et et c'est
vraiment vertueux l'idée étant qu'il
regarde ce qui est fonctionnel si s'il y
a besoin d'une petite réparation et ils
le remettent ensuite dans dans le
circuit via leur filière et ça pourra
servir comme ça à tout un tas d'autres
personnes
exclusivement réservé aux cquantinois le
caisson est pour le moment situé sur un
site pilote mais si l'expérience est
positive l'agglomération prévoit de le
déployer sur d'autres déchetteries dès
2024 en fonction de la place
disponible dans le reste de l'actualité
dimanche 17 septembre la ville de trappe
le Jamel Comedy Club et le Secours
populaire s'unissent pour un gala
caritatif en soutien au sinistrés du
tremblement de terre survenu au Maroc si
humoristes du Jamel Comedy Club se
succèderont sur la scène de la Merise la
totalité des recettes sera versée au
Secours populaire pour financer ses
actions au Maroc mardi 12 septembre la
Fondation Orange a remis des diplômes à
des femmes yvelinoises isolées de
l'emploi accompagné par le Centre
d'Information sur les Droits des femmes
et des familles des Yvelines elles
étaient une vingtaine à avoir suivi des
cours sur des outils numérique dispensé
par la Fondation Orange je suis contente
parce que je connaissais rien dans
l'ordinateur et du coup ça m'a permis
d'être à l'aise et puis c'était un
groupe sympathique quand on venait il y
avait pas de comment je peux dire on se
sentait pas sous-estimé eu deux sessions
ça a duré sur 1 an et beaucoup ne sont
pas là aujourd'hui parce qu'elles sont
par exemple en poste toujours du côté de
l'emploi le centre commercial one nation
Paris et ses magasins recherchent de
nouveaux profils pour renforcer leurs
équipes plus de 50 postes sont à
pourvoir un job dating se tiendra dans
le centre jeudi 14 septembre de 14h à
19h il était important pour nous de
faire ce recrutement déjà pour pouvoir
favoriser le recrutement pour nos
boutiques ça prend beaucoup de temps et
donc nous avons de nouvelles enseignes
nous avons les renforts de fin d'année
plus des événements que nous allons
vivre sur la fin d'année qui nous
demande de renforcer les équipes en
[Musique]
magasin c'est un événement assez unique
parce qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup
du basket TR contre TR sport olympique
il y a des tournois organisés partout il
y a beaucoup de marketing autour alors
nous on voulait faire un truc différent
on joue à 4 contre 4 et on a fait un
tournoi avec 12 équipes on va arriver
bientôt en finale et donc ça va être le
champion du jour il y a pas de l'argent
à gagner c'est que pour le fun et on
veut que ça soit surtout dans une bon
esprit
ça s'appelle playground time pour le
moment il y a très peu de membres mais
nous avons une grosse présence sur les
réseaux sociaux en fait tout est
bénévole et tout ce qu'on veut c'est
proposer au
municipalité de rénover des terrains de
créer des nouveaux terrains et de faire
les bons choix au niveau du
matériel justement pour pas gaspier de
l'argent
public
je peux coacher des jeunes je peux
participer à des événements comme ça à
notre association donc ça me permet de
rester dans le basket mais en tant que
joueur à 67 ans il était temps que je
m'arrête et mon mon
dernier crise cardiaque m'a convaincu
que c'était le moment de stopper
définitivement mais bon j'ai j'ai eu de
la chance qu'il y avait un jeune Maxime
long à côté de moi le jour où je suis
tombé en M subite sur un terrain de
basket j'ai beaucoup de chance et et je
reconnais la chance que j'ai de pouvoir
être ici aujourd'hui face à
[Musique]
vous aujourd'hui je vous présenter
Spider-Man et spiderw un film
d'animation de 2018 qui est le premier
film où on suit du coup miles morales
qui est une des nombreuses itérations de
de Spider-Man dans dans les comics et
pourquoi c'est un film j'ai envie de
vous parler c'est que non seulement
c'est un film qui a à la fois a
transformé un petit peu le monde de
l'animation avec un espèce de mélange de
2D de CGI qui n'avait jamais été
aaramment quand on regarde ce Spider-Man
on a l'impression que c'est les pages du
comic qui prennent vie je m'appelle
miles
morales je suis le seul et unique
Spiderman du moins c'est ce que je
croyais l'accélérateur de particules tu
connais tu vas adorer dimension en cours
d'ouverture tu es comme moi comment
c'est possible on a l'impression de voir
le papier on a l'impression de de sentir
vraiment toute cette façonlà et ça
n'avait jamais été fait VI bon c'est
voilà ce n'est pas que du dessin ce
n'est pas que de la pure 3D c'est un
espèce de mix hybride et ils ont été les
premiers à le faire et donc déjà rien
que pour ça ça vaudrait le coup et
surtout parce que on peut souvent avoir
des a priori en tant G cadule sur les
films d'animation toujours rappeler que
l'animation est une technique et pas ça
veut pas dire que c'est pour un âge
particulier que c'est pr chose l'ation
juste une technique différente mais
Spider-Man c'est vra un film très mature
sur les sujets très très forts et sur
l'adolescence sur grandir sur qu'est-ce
que c'est que le poids des
responsabilités et et c'est un film qui
souscouvert encore une fois de films
d'animation on se dit allez c'est pour
les jeunes c'est pour les enfants je
vais le voir et Ben qui même en tant
qu'adu je peux vous dire vous prend V
trip et vous amène sur une histoire que
vous vous y attendez pas et voilà c'est
je pense tout style confondu pour moi
des meilleurs films de super-héros de
ces dernières années
euh et c'est donc un film à
voir
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Jean-Luc noirbange
je suis secrétaire de l'association
[Musique]
l'éclairando
la caractéristique de notre club c'est
de d'organiser des randonnées euh tout
au long de la semaine et selon des
rythmes et des endroits différents ce
qui est important pour nous c'est trois
objectifs euh la découverte sportive
hein donc le le le fait de faire un un
exercice physique le la découverte de
des différents sites de notre région
hein sachant que le département les
divine et est plein de à la fois de de
forêts de monuments de chemins et donc
très très intéressante en terme de de
découverte et puis enfin et très
important le lien social que l'on
cherche à renforcer développer puisque
c'est vraiment l'occasion en marchant de
découvrir les personnes avec qui on
marche et qui sont des personnes qui
habitent autour de
nous
on a par exemple une randonnée en pleine
ville au visinet qu'on appelle le
circuit des petites rivières qui est
vraiment une un petit circuit plat de 7
km qui va se promener dans des petits
chemins et qui nous permet de découvrir
les très belles demeures de de cette
ville assez Cu des
ivelines un endroit qui est notre un peu
le terrain chasse favorie c'est la forêt
de rambouiller dans la forêt de
rambouiller j'aime beaucoup le un
circuit autour des de l'abaye des
vaaucernet qui est assez valallonné et
avec un au milieu de ça un beau monument
qui est le qui est la bailie des vaau
[Musique]
cernis un autre type de circuit qui va
être un circuit plus à travers champ et
découvert des villages qu'on appelle le
circuit des trois lavoir qui va de
Ben en passant par lavron et TI gignon
et écépière également voilà qui fait une
vingtaine de
[Musique]
kilomètres demain matin nous devrions
avoir les mêmes conditions météo
qu'aujourd'hui nuageux avec quelques
éclaircis au niveau des températures il
fera 15°gr à rambouiller et oudans 16 à
Mantel jolie et 17 à Versailles demain
après-midi le ci ne devrait pas bouger
nous devrions rester au sec côté
température compter 22 à 23°r en moyenne
dans les Yvelines et tout de suite c'est
l'heure de l'invité du 78 avec méanie
[Musique]
poket une journée mondiale du nettoyage
de la planète le World clean up day
c'est notamment ce samedi 16 septembre
et pour en parler avec nous Annie rosba
bonjour bonjour vous êtes responsable de
l'association inimontaine je respecte ma
ville et vous organisez notamment le
rendez-vous sur la commune de Montini
Bretonneux est-ce que déjà vous pouvez
nous rappeler l'importance de ce World
clean UPD oui alors ce qu'il faut que je
dis ce n'est pas que ce samedi ça
commence aujourd'hui et c'est jusqu'à
dimanche en fonction des décalages
horaires parce que c'est un mouvement
planétaire c'est un grand défi mondial
de nettoyage de la planète en un jour
donc il y en a qui commencent
aujourd'hui notamment les entreprises
certaines écoles et puis à travers le
monde en fonction des fusau horaires bah
vont se déployer les cleanurs à travers
la planète pour ramasser le maximum de
déchets alors en 2022 en France c'est
170000 personnes qui se sont mobilisé ça
rassemble ou il faut encore aller
chercher les gens de plus en plus alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que on
observe une migration des citoyens des
comportements c'est-à-dire que ceux qui
jetaient deviennent de vrais cleaners
donc ça veut dire que le message est
entendu et que à force de montrer
l'exemple et ben ça sensibilise vraiment
et on a de plus en plus de personnes
convaincues de plus en plus de personnes
mais aussi un nombre qui augmente chaque
année c'est la quantité de déchets
ramassé c'est très marquant euh la
quantité ça dépend des communes ça
dépend des sites on voit moins de
déchets quand même parce que s'il y a de
plus en plus des gens qui ramassent ça
veut dire qu'il y a de moins de moins en
moins de Polleur voilà l'idée quand même
c'est de se dire que à terme on devra se
poser la question de est-ce qu'on
continue parce qu' il y aura de moins en
moins des
déchets actuellement le déchet le plus
marquant j'en ai même à mes pieds c'est
le MO de cigarettes on en trouve partout
partout notamment dans les hypercentres
parce qu'il y a des bureaux et parce
qu'il y a aussi beaucoup plus de
personnes voilà qui sont dans un moment
de loisir donc qui fument et qui
malheureusement jettent leur mig pas au
bon endroit alors ça mobilise du monde
on l'a dit juste avant tout le monde
peut y participer tout tout le monde
c'est une activité intergénérationnelle
je parlais tout à l'heure des enfants
qui ont commencé le mercredi au senior
alors je parlais de la ville de montinil
Bretonneux c'est ce samedi 16 septembre
la nature qui vient il y a 9 points de
rendez-vous qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça
veut dire qu'on embarque tous les tous
les quartiers tous les habitants de la
ville parce qu'on a envie que notre
ville reste propre et c'est la 5e
édition avec la ville et la 6e avec
l'association ça va se passer comment
vous dites on embarque après tout le
monde se balade déjà on a déjà embarqué
parce que c'est la 5e fois qu'on le fait
et il y a toujours beaucoup de succès il
y a 9 points de de départ dont un à
l'île de loisir c'est le 8e en fait on a
un double point la surerie qui est un
grand quartier d'où d'où de double point
et puis le point qu'on a rajouté c'est
la porte de la digue à la derrière le
vélodrome ce sont des points marquants
de la ville c'est des points de
rassemblement c'est des point visuel où
les gens se retrouvent plus facilement
vous attendez combien de personnes bah
écoutez comment plus ça tombe souvent le
le weekend des journées mondiales des
journées pardon des journées du du
patrimoine
une gros
concurence mais bon on espère qu'on aura
beaucoup plus de C je n'ai pas vraiment
de de chiffres à vous dire voil ramasser
des déchets ça peut inquiéter aussi on
peut parfois tomber sur des choses un
peu dangereuses est-ce qu'il y a une
tenue à prendre absolument il faut pas
venir un tau aiguille bien entendu ni
enocass un pompon ce qu'il faudra c'est
des baskets adaptés un jeans et surtout
et surtout des gants et je précise bien
des gants avec embout
renforce ça passe voilà pour qu'il y ait
pas de Tesson pour qu'il y ait pas de
tesson de bouteille pour qu'il y ait pas
de d'épines ou des choses ou des choses
qui piquent d'ailleurs je suis très
fière de cell-là c'est
les et vous avez aussi dans la main un
appareil très important PCE voilà et
voilà j'ai une pince parce qu'il y a des
personnes malheureusement qui voilà ne
peuvent pas se baisser pour diverses
raisons et qui voilà et puis il y a des
déchets qui sont dans les buissons qu'on
ne peut pas forcément aller chercher
très très loin donc il faut quand même
une pince pour aller tracter voilà ce
qui est entre les buissons ça fait 5 ans
que vous êtes à avec la commune de
Montini sur organisation un partenariat
avec la ville de Montini de mten
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé alors à vous
mobiliser alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que l'association je respecte ma
ville et une association éccitoyenne qui
sensibilise au respect du cadre de vie
donc qui dit cadre de vie qui dit beauté
ça veut dire que tout ce qui n'est pas à
sa place en terme des déchets nuit au
Bien Vivre Ensemble donc du coup on
cherchait quand on a créé l'association
une
activité qui mettrait les les citoyens
face à leur gestes délicat donc du coup
on a eu connaissance donc du work day et
on s'est dit bah tiens ça ça correspond
tout à fait aux activités qu'on a envie
de faire dans l'association et c'est
comme ça que la première édition l'
d'abord fait toute seule enfin seule
avec les membres de l'association dans
un quartier et comme ça avait eu
relativement du succès et qu'on avait eu
la demande pour l'année d'après on s'est
dit pourquoi on ne ferait pas dans toute
la ville et comme ça il y aurait
plusieurs
points exactement merci Annie rosma de
nous avoir accordé cet entretien alors
pour découvrir les différents
rendez-vous proposé par les communes de
saintquanttin en ville n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur leur site internet mais
aussi celui de l'agglomération qui
recense tous les points de rendez-vous à
noter que des communes comme morpa et
voisin de Bretonneux leur rendez-vous
eux c'est le 17 septembre c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve sur notre site
Internet et nos réseaux sociaux belle
soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78